you
[Music]
this morning on the dish Houston chef
who's earning a texas-sized reputation
growing up in Oklahoma Chris Shepards
first hospitality job was washing dishes
in a Japanese restaurants then the
tempura chef position opened up and
before long he was hooked making his way
to Houston Shepard eventually opened
underbelly and ode to the city's
immigrant cuisine winning a 2014 James
Beard Award for Best Chef Southwest now
he's moved on opening Georgia James ub
preserve and one fifth and this year won
another top honor the rod report named
him their worldwide chef of the year and
his very first cookbook cooked like a
local came out in September for Shepherd
good morning and welcome to the dish
holy smokes man you win a lot of just
couple of things from the book but kind
of shows the diversity of our city so
Little J over on the other side which is
just a Korean sweet potato noodle dish
kind of a Szechuan style eggplant dish
and then something that's really kind of
key to our city well fajitas always but
just under the Vietnamese style so
marinate a fish sauce and chilies and
then you just basically wrap it up and
do a little bit of lettuce roasted
butternut squash with bacon jam and
granola and then green curry pancakes
with a sweet soy syrup and which is kind
of a tiki drink tiki spices and Jeff
mentioned all there were all the awards
but I want to start with the book
because in it it's not just the recipes
you also talk a lot about these
immigrant populations and their food and
why it's so important what would draw
you what drew you to that I should say
it was learning more about our city and
so when we started talking about the
book we a lot of times people focus on
we talk about local the aspect of local
food right okay we're your apples from
where your lettuce is from but what we
wanted to focus on is the cultures that
exist in to your city and learning more
from that and so you can be part of your
community and learn and celebrate
everybody you went as far as Vietnam to
really sort of
weshall of that out yeah we decided that
we needed to take a trip to Vietnam so I
could learn more about Houston these
populations in the city and I wanted to
know where is that going now and so it
was we spent a couple weeks going up and
down and really learned a lot about
Houston it's one thing I think people
outside Houston a lot of people don't
understand is first how diverse Houston
is and second how great the food is
including that over there more about
that so it was like we wanted to do this
dish and I was talking to my pastry chef
and I was like this stat I really like
green curry and I think it'd be really
delicious in pancakes and then if you do
she was like well what kind of syrup is
this based on I was like well sweet soy
you know it's naturally sweet but a
little bit of salt and then just like
put a lot of lime zest and citrus into
it and then candied peanuts and it's
just it's one of those perfect desserts
when you talk about all the different
foods in Houston one of your restaurants
that's so fascinating one-fifth each
year it's been a different cuisine
you're on your fourth now isn't there
temptation at the end of each year to
keep it going or how have you been able
to manage that like if it's working why
not keep it going you know it was it was
the idea that it would be the playground
to figure out what we wanted to do next
what was the next restaurant and it was
the opportunity that you don't normally
get you spent a lot of money into a
restaurant you hope it really works well
this we could see by running it for 11
months
does it there's a good do we do this in
the future
yeah and so yeah I mean we just did the
eastern Mediterranean was really popular
and successful but it was hard to change
but we had to go you know you got to
keep doing its Gulf Coast right now but
I really love that one too and then your
five I have to make a decision here
pretty soon yeah you did what I have no
clue
[Laughter]
how do we decide that back it's it's you
know it's talking on the chef and talk
with the staff talking to everybody
there and see them what they're
passionate about because if they're if
nobody's passionate about it then it
just doesn't work it's not how you
maintain quality and control as you
expand and open new places it's just
passion yeah it's if you can you you
can't teach heart and that's what we
talk about all the time when we go
through hiring processes and how we how
we talk about our staff and you can't
teach heart you can teach everything
else but you just can't teach the
intangible of really caring and wanting
to learn and wanting to do better and
wanted to you know be good with your
staff and be good with your clients I'm
gonna have you sign our dish and if you
can have this meal with anyone past your
present who would it be you guys right
now oh oh my goodness right now and so I
think this is a perfect setting what
we're doing that's it go ahead and sign
and thank you so much Chris we
appreciate if you want more on Chris
Shepherd or the dish you can head to our
website
cBS This Morning Calm
you